[Applause]  Naomi is like a revelation to me six  extraordinary Talent people know her a  bit but I think people are  really going to know her after this  maybe maybe it's Gotta Have a hook a  hook yeah  I'll give it a hook  it's just so much fun this is a  beautiful tribute to Whitney Houston one  of the greatest talents we'll ever see  she was fabulous she was a genius  Whitney Houston was a genius this is  what they want America's sweetheart and  you're gonna give it to him just watch  me  and naomiaki she's the real deal  we're really taking you on a musical  Journey it's a really good time you get  to go to the concert have that full  experience in all of its hugeness  I want to dance with somebody rated  PG-13 exclusively in movie theaters